MALE SPEAKER: In this video,
I'll cover how to pass
arguments to existing functions
inside the functions
you are creating.
To do so I'll use the website,
Revenue Data, highlighted in
the last section.
I'd like to create a function
that summarizes the revenue
and other objects like it.
I'll call the function,
RevSummary.
And it'll take just one argument
that should be a data
frame, or a matrix, where the
rows represent days, columns
represent different websites,
and entries represent revenue
for the websites on each day.
I'll build in a simple check
to make sure that the data
object comes in in a form of
a matrix or a data frame.
If it doesn't, then I'll provide
a suitable error.
Next, I'll calculate two
summaries, the average revenue
per company and the
average revenue
per day for the companies.
In a previous video, I used the
Apply function for this,
but here I'll use two
functions that are
specifically built for taking
the Mean across rows and
columns, rowMeans
and colMeans.
I'll return those results in a
list with two items that will
be returned at the close of the
function, mean revenue per
company, and mean
revenue per day.
Finally, I'll apply my new
function to the revenue data.
When I execute the function, I
get a list back, as expected.
However, there are some n/a
values that indicate that some
data are missing.
Here I'll identify which
observations in the revenue
data are missing using the is
n/a function together with the
which function, and an
additional argument, array
index equals true.
The first is for the 12th day
and the third company.
The second is for the 13th day
It's possible that some end
users of this function,
including myself, may
occasionally want to have such
observations omitted from the
calculations in the functions
using an n/a argument, similar
to how we've seen this
argument used with
other functions.
However, this n/a remove
argument would need to be
passed to both row Means
and col Means.
This is fine, but it's actually
a little bit more
generalizable to accept an
arbitrary number of arguments
be passed to these functions.
I can do this using an ellipsis
in RevSummary's
declaration.
This allows the RevSummary
function to accept extra
arguments not specified in
the function declaration.
Next, I indicate which functions
should receive these
extra arguments.
Since my intention here is to
allow users to pass the n/a
remove argument to rowMeans
and colMeans I will add an
ellipsis to the end of each
of these functions.
Now, if I pass n/a remove
equals true into the
RevSummary function, this
argument will be passed to the
rowMeans and colMeans functions,
which will then
remove the n/a values from
the calculations.
Note that if you want, you may
access the arguments from the
ellipsis in your function using
the List function with
an ellipsis as its argument.
In this way, you may also write
functions that allow for
an arbitrary number of
arguments, and then access all
of those arguments in a list.
What's been covered in this
video is how to easily pass
additional arguments inside
your functions, and how to
access those extra arguments
using the List function.
In the next video, I'll show
how to hide function output
that might flood a
user's screen.
And I'll also cover a useful
tool for building recursive
functions, which are functions
that call themselves.